[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this brief video i'm going to be
discussing and sharing with you
the preliminary sketch of harry potter
and the dursleys
the sketch in question was done by none
other than jk rowling
herself and while rowling didn't create
the final artwork
though she may have done a bit of it she
would often sketch out her characters
during the writing process
to help aid with their creation the
jerseys
as we know were awful to harry from the
day that harry was placed on their
doorstep
they treated him badly and though they
knew of his existence while harry's
parents were still alive
they never made any attempts to get to
know him the immediate dursley family
was comprised of
vernon desley harry's uncle and primary
torturer
petunia dursley harry's aunt and his
mother's sister
and dudley dursley a boy nearly the same
age as harry with half the brains and
twice the appetite
the dursleys were always massively
critical of harry they didn't like
anything that was out of the ordinary
and all of a sudden they were faced with
raising this magical young boy
almost immediately they were hard on him
and showed clear and obvious favoritism
toward their actual son
dudley they forced harry to live in a
cupboard under the stairs
tried to prevent him from attending
hogwarts it is passed from him
and basically made his life miserable
while he did eventually end up attending
hogwarts thanks to hagrid
and was able to get away from them for a
good portion of the year
he did still have to return to their
tormentous home year
after year this is because he didn't
have a choice
for the only way that he was safe from
voldemort was if he could still call the
home of the dursleys
his own this is thanks to lily's loving
sacrifice
the jerseys were always meant to be
emphasized in heavy contrast with harry
and that's why if you look at this
preliminary sketch from rowling
you'll see a stark difference in the way
that harry's depicted relative to them
given that this drawing far preceded the
films i think he does a pretty good job
depicting the essence of these
characters
and i'm even more impressed with the
casting of richard griffiths aka vernon
who looks just like rolling sketch just
examining the photo more closely
you'll see that the darcy family members
are sporting scowls
while harry who has the worst life out
of the bunch still makes sure to smile
for the photo
this is a good representation of the
type of people that the dursleys were
sour regardless of their situation harry
who is downtrodden and basically has
nothing going for him still has humanity
which they lack
additionally the dursleys are
intentionally depicted as
large while harry sports a baggy shirt
emphasizing his
frailty this photo though just a
preliminary sketch
actually tells us a lot about their
characters as well as their relationship
with harry i love looking at pieces of
harry potter history like this
and i hope you guys do as well that's it
for this brief video
as always leave your video suggestions
down below until next time
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher what not to do
how not to be
you